yeah low and welcome to this video I
often had the request of doing game some
on video that I played over the board so
real long-term control tournament games
and um here's one going to present you a
game that I played um just a couple of
days ago in the Dutch league first
league of the Netherlands called mystic
Lhasa the master class
yeah well it's a rather strong league
but if it yeah masterful chess I don't
know that's yeah let's look at my game
opponent here is German grandmaster it's
quite funny he only lives a couple of
mouths away from my home but we both
traveled to the Netherlands to play this
game and it's quite funny that I'm that
I play him again because he's really an
old acquaintance I played him first 22
years ago when we both were who were
young still I was 16 and he was 17 I
guess and we had a couple of games over
the years and it has been even before
this game so let's see what happens as
mentioned he's a grandmaster rated 2480
or something around this so let's see
him how the game progresses play d4
usually does that not f6 Knight f3
yeah not f3 he often plays um I need to
mention that I didn't do any preparation
for the game in the Dutch league you
never know who exactly you're going to
play so you have no chance to to do a
specific preparation but what I know is
um my usual move here would be would be
e 6 to be flexible about what to do next
move so let's say after c4 that I can
also play maybe this move for all the
Queens and yet other stuff but I know
that he likes to play here the color
system which is not the most dangerous
opening around but I know that he's got
a very good score with this
he usually continues with b3 but should
be to Bishop d3 this Bishop d3 and yes I
had Ted some very nice games with this
so I didn't want to go into that and
played d5 straight away and so I'm after
after d5 if you now play e3 black has
more options then after after the early
u6 of course the six would be fine here
but now I can play moves like g6 or c5
for I simply don't have this Bishop box
then have more options and this is why
played c4 so going back to the normal
Queens gambit I played a six-night c3
Bishop d7 so this is the classical
Queens gambit declined which is my black
option um if I don't really have
anything specific prepared than I often
use this as a fallback option because
it's very solid and you don't um yeah
you rarely get some surprise in the
opening that you don't know how to react
to yeah I played Bishop f4 now the
longtime main line here is Bishop g5
which can lead to all kinds of
variations like the Tata cover or the
Lasker defense but in the recent years
um Bishop f4 has pretty much become the
main roof as black is very solid both in
the last kind the tar take over but
Bishop f4 also on has been played a lot
in recent years and Black has ways to
defuse this also the Queens gambit
declined is very solid for black Ted III
now and I now played Knight B to d7
which is the modern mainline of this
opening for four decades c5 was the main
move and it's still pretty much okay for
black this is much much sharper though
he can hear white can for example play
things like things like this which is
obviously much sharper that bt7 has has
some other idea the ideas that white at
this point has two basic options he can
decide to play c4 c5 gaining space on
the queenside probably intending to
increase this further or you can play
any other move of course
and after this black would play c5 we
see that in the game c5 oops
c5 um black has two options you can play
c6 and then continue with b6 a5 Bishop
a6 getting rid of this bad bishop or I
can claim as kramnik does not h5 which
is probably even um more accurate you
get rid of this bishop and then you play
c6 b6 and after that trying to get rid
of the bishop yeah black is very solid
TM and I don't think that white has any
a huge hope for an advantage all in all
this line is is rather solid so white um
has begun to begin to experiment you
with other moves and these are moves
that anticipate black playing c5 next
move black is not planning to do to do
anything passive here I don't want to
play c6 or something you want to play c5
all the time another main move here
which also anticipates c5 is a3 and then
you get c5 in the game you played h3
which is quite similar I continued c5
and now he played an uncommon move just
not bad but it's uncommon played the
rook to c1 I only found two or three
games of this normal would be m2 capture
on d5 95 95 85 takes takes now black has
got nice laid upon but he's threatening
a queen a5 here in this position and
whiter
pretty much has to play a three that's
not much choice and we see in the game a
very similar position will arise the
problem is if you play a normal
developing move then this Queen f5 oops
Queen a 5-ounce it's very annoying
you cannot respond with the natural
Queen d2 as then ninety three happens
this would win the Queen and yeah this
means you must move the King now which
you really don't want so you really need
to play a three at some point in the
game he played as mentioned this rooks
he won't move here I have various
possibilities at the end I decided to
play a six and this is a kind of a
waiting move and that sort of asked why
okay what are you doing now if you don't
want to take on d5 what are you doing
now it's difficult to play on any M yeah
tempo move the kind of move which tries
to recapture on c4 in one move the
problem is if what would play a three
it's not bad yeah but it it's not
helping much I have the idea to take and
play b5 in one move this is the idea of
a six and now if y2 treats then you can
simply continue developing and have a
very very comfortable position all
black's pieces are positioned nicely and
you don't have any kind of problem black
is very comfortable here this is why
taking on c4 is a bit of a threat really
at least them it would yeah East blacks
task considerably so he took on d5 and
now took of the night it's very
important to to to take with the night
and not take with the pawn we see in the
game why and why this is important one
point is after the exchange and white
now take taking on c5 that that in the
game
we see that Queeny reversal is the idea
but why white can also ignore all this
and just develop but this can be
answered with this move it's one idea
I'd also by c4 which is the kind of move
you want to play if you are trying to
win the game going for majority here
trying to unbalance the position it's a
bit risky but it's playable okay he took
on c5 so it doesn't really met him
oops yeah it took on c5 and I'm not just
recaptured and now a3 the problem is
that there was still this threat of
Queen a5 a 2 was also just hanging so
this is a necessary move so this is some
an interesting version of the isolated
pawn in fact um this often arises with
the very similar structure but with
different moves by white so III says
almost always some plate in this
structure rook c1 not solved an h3 also
not solved and a success
well debatable it doesn't it doesn't
help much but it's not much of a problem
I played Bishop f5 now which is a
standard way of playing thus the ideas
you want to go with the bishop to e4 926
and Bishop to f6 the idea is to place
the pieces in a way that our pieces
fight for this d4 square in fact black
is a little bit better developed here if
you look at this African all pieces into
play after Bishop f5 and white still has
bishop here and hasn't canceled so he
needs some time to get the King out of
the middle and in fact this is why black
is that's very fine him that's a matter
of time
he played now Bishop e2 that's not not
much else
you need to get castles prepared and
then and now Bishop to reform
castles and ninety-six and so now we see
that white is very far away from getting
a piece established on deform played
Bishop b5 not and Bishop f6 and yeah now
it is it's tricky already I'm
threatening to take on f3 already and
then this Bishop would be hanging so if
he doesn't nothing move I mean indeed
played to Queen d2 which protects me too
so this is it's not so great in
comparison if you look at this I cannot
take on v2 now and I have problems too
to secure this pawn so taking on after
Queen d2 wasn't so great but what I
played in the game was perfectly okay
Queen d2 I took on e5 recaptured yeah
and he I have a choice and maybe should
have gone for the other continuation no
it's it's very young very draws what I
could could play I could play d4 did
this one but default would have been
very draw I wasn't so sure in the game
of course if you have the chance to
advance here isolated pawn and get rid
of it it's the first thing you you
consider and what I wasn't so sure of is
this kind of position if this is really
completely equal here this bit of
pressure on f7 but after the game I
looked at this and just this move and
Bishop d5 pretty much kills the game to
draw it's simply nothing after this so
this was a very easy way to to equalize
completely this is
bitte yeah it's a bit of smaller fight
after this like Nazi flow of course I
saw this idea
Quincy 795 I really expected this to
happen because he's really a really a
fighter it's not it's not a yeah a
player who likes to play draw so it was
pretty clear that we get this position
and I thought I would be okay here I am
now but my consideration was that this
night is of course it's attacking b7 so
I need to have a look at this but I have
good control of a default can default
some other point so I didn't see any
problems here and I don't have any
problems but it was just the other
continuation was just much simpler to
play in comparison so um it's perfectly
all right what I did um yeah he here he
surprised me I was really expecting this
kind of move after which I probably play
I'm just just the normal move like look
T a drop c8 something like this and it's
about equal he played them f3 which I
really didn't expect it looks very
weakening here this this kind of squares
but it's it's not like black can easily
exploit this that some he wanted to get
rid of the bishop only form but still I
was surprised okay I need to retreat and
King to to h1 young-ok wants to step out
of the diagonal him group p8 in order to
support deform before yeah okay not
anchoring the night so that nothing
happens to it if in case what wants to
move the Queen rook e8 yeah maybe I
could have saved the tempo here with
rook d7 immediately but it's not much of
a difference we reach a position here
yeah a nice improvement the bishop won't
be three putting some pressure on d5 and
I just cover this
and rookie one yeah now we have a
position where um both sides have
improved their pieces and it's rather
difficult to make any progress
I met up at age six yeah just
strengthening the position so that I
have have some moved here for the king
so no Becker I made that Queen f2 yeah
and it's uh yeah as mentioned um
difficult to make any progress even if I
am I don't do anything here just to just
stay out like moving with the Queen
nothing much would happen but here I
have a chance um which I which I took
yeah I played Knight f4 and using the
the pin and the idea is simply to to go
to d3 I'm winning the exchange yeah
white doesn't have much of an
alternative here play Bishop to c2 and I
thought this mr. Bishop exchange should
help me and I think it's it's very okay
and now I'll just talk back so the
bishops are off this is the main effect
of this Knight f4 move yeah played rock
to d2 slow applying pressure on the pawn
and now Queen c7 my idea was to get this
move in or to improve the Queen to e5
like King to g1 yeah I'm not quite sure
what this move is doing to be honest
some may be just a waiting move Queen e5
Knight b3 yeah so here Y term probably
intense night to learn to to deform I
couldn't Convention on an alternative
actually here in this position I forgot
this I could also play here
this would be a very solid choice with
the idea to play rook C 3 a possible
continuation is this one and black gets
the pawn back end
a completely equal position okay but
what I played was sauce perfectly
alright Queenie five-night iam yeah now
white maybe intense play 94 and I don't
want to have the Knights exchange this
would help white getting um let's say I
play a play nothing movie I'm okay just
just for argument's sake I didn't want
this position to happen because now he
has ideas lucky for you were tripling on
this pawn and this this can get a bit
passive for black it's still probably
not terrible but I don't need to get
into this this is why play group c7 here
intending rock c3 you need to get
counter play I mean all this what what
was doing also weakened the position and
I have only one weaknesses d5 but White
has quite quite a number of weaknesses
it's not bad yeah I'm not saying white
is worse but I need to get on to those
weaknesses and have some play myself
yeah he played afore yeah this is really
a sharp move you need to know I'm the
time control it's really a really
important for this game what some he and
then the clocks displayed is complete
it's nonsense from from ICC here just
some standard display we played two
hours for forty moves and then one hour
for the rest of the game and we are more
move 32 and we both well on let's say
about maybe three or four minutes left
not quite sure about this if I was
really risky I'm pretty sure I wouldn't
have played this s white but okay he's
he wants to wants to get some fight
going
it allows neither for me and I was happy
to play this to responded not C 5 yeah
this is also good I think white could
take him it's not not terrible after
this I have choices I can I can play
this but also a simple reply would have
been in this kind of stuff
and it's pretty equal it's not much not
much happening really it's helpful that
this is this squares on a weekend this
always some gives me enough counter
plain but okay as mentioned to him he
wanted to fight him plate 95 and this
keeps the tension the night is obviously
I'm not bad on c5 but it's also it's a
bit risky him okay deform I now can play
before um yeah due to technical reasons
of course what cannot take here as some
there is the for Connie to this is also
why King G one was a bit helpful as I
mentioned I wasn't quite sure why I
played it it's ok what cannot take on d4
and now I have a passport my isolated
pawn has become a passed pawn I know why
what needs to be a bit cautious yeah he
played King edge one back in order to
attack the spawn and he had a good move
I have lady to pupate b6 which is strong
right now on plate Knight b3 really
needs to do this he cannot take on a six
because of just this booth look see for
this secures the d4 pawn and I'm
covering it with all my pieces basically
and then a six-night is completely off
side
I cannot win it outright but it simply
is so badly positioned here I have this
kind of ideas and why it really needs to
play some weird stuff to secure it I
mean think even b5 honey something needs
to play so this is really nonsense
taking on a6 he immediately went back to
b3 and now of course the pawn is
attacked again but I have my counter
play rock c3 group deform and sorry 94
of course took her with a knife it was
an alternative actually to take with the
rugged maybe this is this was better
um I can simply take here no it takes
and ruk a three and this should be
perfectly alright for black I mean I
don't have any any big problems um the
funny line here just just to illustrate
of course we didn't see any of this with
you know two minutes on the clock but
this is quite funny if you look at this
Knight f5 and white is threatening on b6
here the fun thing is if black just
plays a waiting move then this is a
really fun drawing line white cannot
take on g2 with the king
yes this leads to to winning a tech yeah
this is kind of stuff even-even will end
in checkmate so 92 needs to be amped was
the fun move rook g1 and I cannot
retreat the light because that's g7
hanging with the with the f5 not
attacking it
but this cm is actually a draw what can
what can play this the only move quit f4
and this kind of stuff is funny enough a
draw okay well cuz we didn't see any of
this he took on D form with with the
night and now I just captured a on a3
getting the pawn back yeah in fact them
here black already um it's a bit better
it's simply this is the strong Knight
and white now played 96 yeah maybe the
computer recommends Queen f1 here but
just to really a pure computer move I
don't see any human going for this
especially with two minutes on the clock
and about this we really didn't have
much okay
played 96 looks normal of course I have
ripped it to um it's
not losing material Queen d2 yeah rook
t2 during the game I thought would be
terrible in fact the computer shows that
it is playable but it looks weird Queen
e2 is just much more much more natural
and yeah now Queen g5 it was attacked by
the Knights oh yeah and now this is the
problem these pieces put pressure on g2
and White needs to react to this if I
think you only yes you played now Queen
to d8 was just really the kind of move
to play in time travel you want to get
rid of the Queens yeah I was threatening
route III of course winning so um this
was the problem okay get this check and
now of course I don't take here but I
play king intercept which is much
stronger keeping the threat alive on g2
and now why doesn't have much choice he
needs to exchange yeah and now we got
the endgame a very interesting endgame
and the thing is some black is very
active with this configuration always
attacking g2 and I've got two against
one on the Queen side so I've got a
potential past poem here the a pawn so
it's clear that dumb black is somewhat
better but it's not so not so clear how
much um one one thing is which is
important this was a team match and our
team were awesome
was behind two points with only two
games running the other game we had
winning shots and this game so I really
needed to try to win so this is
important to know if you look at the
further course of the game you need to
try everything possible to win
yeah played rook d2 here there was an
alternative with rook d7 but I don't
want this to be an hour long because we
have much stuff ahead of still it was
very exciting now yeah rook t2 am and
here maybe here I am I played
maybe I played the wrong idea I'm not
I'm not so sure it's it's very very
difficult even afterwards to to analyze
I played 93 which looks for me very
natural
the idea being look here look here of
course if this is not hanging and try to
win this pawn simply we see in the game
that it's not so easy a good alternative
would have been just playing a5 and this
leads to to a position where the only
black hand winner and white has very
little counter play this is some the
main difference to the game I played it
a much sharper and white got a ton of
counter play yeah on this position black
is better but it's not so clear for you
can really win an interesting defense
here's g3 attacking the knight and try
to get rid of this it's very it's very
annoying on a form the the ideas that
this muth is probably not good now as
now the the knight is trapped and you
need to play g4 even to keep it not to
lose it completely then f4 and you're
really playing without this piece now I
think this should be fine for white it's
not totally clear but it should be fine
black and player can play ideas like f6
and and g5 taking this pawn but I I
don't think you can win basically
without the knight so taking would be
would be bad probably so retreating is
certainly better then King g2 and then
they form this kind of position the a
pawn is dangerous and yeah one question
is is this rook and gamma draw
I'm not sure probably it is but black
has chances does the second-ranked yes
the problem I'm controlling the
second-ranked
and I'm not 100% sure of this it should
be a win like it's better but the main
point is white has no chance at all to
get anything maybe this would have been
better it's really difficult to tell
look at the game it's impossible to
foresee what what happened really I hope
I hope you don't see instantly that that
this is risky what I did okay played
whoopsie - and he of course them I can
if I want I can I can just draw with
them with any move group III for example
can even play a 5 now the play would be
3 he just probably returns I mean black
has some oops no sorry it's a play here
and I mean this kind of stuff for
example I could play and I can never
lose the game but of course I must try
to win and at the end I decided to play
a rope to a form attacking the pawn this
was the idea of 93 after all and he just
returned to the tomb pretty much
inviting me to take ya here ok 3 is of
course a direct draw because of you can
just really return and we could repeat
moves but of course I I took on before
in the game also thought I would be
better but analyzing it now in more
detail with the computer yeah the
computer sounds really without any mercy
it simply tells me that it's a draw all
along but ok let's see what happens I
took here and of course wider needs to
seek how to play I played 98 attacking
the spawn
yeah and this is the problem
White has counterplay now he's attacking
f7 and he threatens to enter with the
rook and yeah I played a check first and
f6 an alternative would have been king
g6 but it's not clear what this really
accomplishes this is very similar to the
game we see em in the game can f6 rook
d7 and this is the counter play Knight
oops
Knight to d6 and attacking g7 of course
I have ta born so let's see what happens
I pushed the pawn and you need to be
quickly I cannot lose any kind of move
926 and a form yeah here White has a
choice and he took on g7 with a knight
he could have also taken with the rook
which also as a draw there are some fun
ways to lose the game actually here I
could lose if he would take on you stand
and I would play now King to h6 white
wind was rook d7 and he wins instantly
with mate as checkmate right f8 rook h7
I cannot I cannot prevent this
it's very funny it's no way to prevent
this this is checkmate and about five
moves yeah no no way to prevent it
so after this some and I had to take to
go here and then not f7 and now he's
just giving checks and it's not much
what I can do stuff like this if I try
to win here King to to g6 then we have
this stuff again and it's still made
even two extra moves the iPhone didn't
help at all so it's still night f8 and
check medium looking at a 2 not afraid I
can even play this yeah we can just
ignore it
and it's checkmate that's really really
funny so white has very very strong girl
to play obviously so um this would have
been at the end
whoops sorry I need to I need to go back
in then so that's the draw he took with
the night zone which also was okay it's
not a mistake
no it takes and yeah a three I need to
push my porn
yeah and now night - um h5 check an
alternative was not f5 but after this I
can again drop back to to the
eighth-ranked and it's not clear how he
continues he only has a check and I
escaped with the King so night h5 was
much strong and also was the idea yeah
here I went to g6 which is the sharpest
tribe if I would go to h8 it's simple
made next move and he'll go to g8 it's
an immediate draw this was one of the
draws that I could always have but I
couldn't do it Jim I needed to win for
the team result so this is very obvious
draw and White has noted no other option
I just play a two rook rook away from a1
and then promote so he must must make
the draw okay King g6 trying to win now
jeez feedback yeah now now I tried as to
try the sharpest winning idea play - f5
and if it will play a - then Knight f5
and funny again I can have a look at
this line yeah and now white threatens
rook g7 check King age 5 and G for
checkmate and this noise so if I would
play some some mid say player
nothing move then it's this checkmate
checkmate yeah very nice
so this is a draw again and I needed to
avoid this yeah so of course it's it's
it's a draw I can just check to till
yeah till it's tomorrow yeah it's very
easy to draw but it was not enough so I
played played this f 5 mph
avoiding the the draw he took on f5 note
that if you would take with the night
then I just played this Andrew k1 and he
has no no meeting net or anything this
is probably an easy wooden I say
probably because there may be some some
strange kind of fortresses that that are
available but okay this is nonsense to
take with the night he took with with
the pawn it's much better King here yeah
I want to try to win if I go here
it doesn't help much he's got 94 and it
gets very tricky again let's say 8 a 2
trying to win then there's this move and
yeah rook h1 he just plays this and it's
made next move or kick and played this
kind of desperado but and I made on h7
so um I need to go here the only move
now root D 6 again the only move to be
honest them I was really surprised when
I analyzed this before and even analyzed
this at home that we didn't make really
any big mistakes in this kind of in this
in this phase of the game the only
problem was that it really was
time-consuming to calculate all this
stuff so Rock d6 um came to f7 and roof
takes b6 so
yeah rupee one I need to make some some
way a form for the pawn if I would play
a two here then white can simply take
problem is that I've got I have given
away so much materially already that
getting a new queen really doesn't help
and something like this I mean the only
player playing for when here's white so
I need to I need to play this first
isn't it in the game yet up at night
before and now we see that Knight g5 and
the F pawn gives some plenty of play a
295 the problem is you can easily lose
this black I mean I had to calculate all
this stuff and this believe me it isn't
it isn't easy
okay I'm not g5 check and apply to King
to e8 an alternative you need to look at
this King to 2 g8 but first let's check
here this even losers f6 and yeah it's
difficult maybe 95 here yeah 95 I can
still play and not lose but okay it's
not it's not great also what now
threatening checkmate yeah okay well I
guess I went to a 2 yet but let's like
look quickly at King g8 what's happening
Venice is this move and it's it's
similar to to the game we can let's say
here epsilon and what now
I go here he's got this stuff and yeah
King g7 he stopped this move and this is
a perpetual I didn't see this in the
game I'm not pretending I calculated all
this Qing Yi aid which are played in
this position King yet is just simpler
to to look at it and this is really the
only kind of try that offers realistic
winning ideas f6a one Queen that saw or
force f7 check King b7 e + f8 Queen so
we both got a new queen but what what I
calculated I mean really lots not to
lose before what's this rook h1 check
King G 325 check and this is this what
the idea of all this I mean I have like
rifice three pawns
after all the idea was that now this
rook is hanging and whatever he does he
will lose the rook so if he plays queen
f4 which is the simplest of course I
just win the rook and get the Queen's
off should should win relatively easy
then it's got King here then I have this
move picking up the rook and the best
move what he played in the game f4 I
have Queen III picking up the rook so
Knight f3 was played and Queen b6 yeah
and after all this I have an extra look
but have no pawns and the King is just
wide open on D 795 check he played and
now King see Sapna have no other I have
no other move otherwise I'd just lose
the Queen I mean why should I go at this
one
who's the queen so only move was King
here and he in fact um he made a mistake
but what's very important to note at
this point we had something like and I
was down to maybe two or three minutes
and he was down to four or something for
the rest of the game yeah so it's it's
pretty much down to a blitz game now
quick blitz came here Queen f7 would
have drawn but this is impossible to
tour serially for for a human in this
town control you need to need to go here
otherwise I'm I'm in some some some fork
again Queen f5 check this is the point
and if I try to run out run out of this
need to go here and then not c4 is very
strong as this Knight controls III this
is the point I cannot give this check
now I have no check at all in fact and
white has this this check ideas and this
you can check it with the computer if
you like it's really a draw with
perpetual check to come impossible to
see and this time the difference between
what he played he played played Queen a7
check and the difference is really a
impossible to to spot yeah King c8 must
play that no other move Queen to f8 and
King b7 so Queen f7 King a6 so I ran to
to the fr um right here why just one
more check going to be five quincy a
check and king a5 so I try to find
shelter here near the near the pieces
yeah and now white um doesn't really
have any meaningful check left
so um he played h4 yeah and now I'm with
less than two minutes on the clock I
made the first really bad move I think
the really the first where he better
move in the game I think it was
remarkable we didn't really make any
huge mistakes for 68 moves and I didn't
really expect that during the game I
thought I were you certainly missed
stuff and he also has it's very normal
if he checked with the computer
afterwards that that you find mistakes
but there was really a really little in
this game yeah I played now look do you
want the idea is very human I want to
get the route back trying to help with
the defense but I simply overlooked a
move but he also he also overlooked it
and now white simply could play Knight
c4 check and yeah it's really simple I
mean it's just a blunder whatever I did
here I need to go here and then there's
this it's very very easy and mean but
you also missed it you also really must
know if you if you don't play tournament
chess yourself playing with two minutes
on the clock
after six hours of a complicated game is
different to a casual blitz game it's
really a different situation you're
simply worn out after six hours yeah but
okay this would have happened
John give this check and we had would
have this kind of position and I think
he watch has very decent winning chances
maybe I can get some kind of perpetual
on the king but the aged pawn it's much
easier to play this with with minute was
just a minute on the clock for white
just push the pawns yeah well he didn't
play Nancy for he played just h5 and
maybe maybe he was really expecting it
my next move I would this is just it's
very difficult to play and what I should
play back to back to back
back here what I should play here is
actually Queen d5 which is strong this
protects the apron of the ADEA da-a-ate
square and white cannot cannot check
here yeah I mean the computer for for
example certainly would win this is
black but it's it's not easy at all the
evaluation of you if you trust the trust
the compares just a 0.7 for black it's
not like +3 or something that you have
something concrete and it's tricky to
play with the bad King position but this
is what I should have played okay so
root d1 was a blunder page 5 yeah and
now came the final blunder with about a
minute on the clock yeah this is really
a really simple but what can I say I
played would be six year and yeah you
don't probably don't need a long time to
to find Queen c7 and hmm yeah you cannot
really do anything against this if you
need to go here and then this is Big
Fork and I'd simply lose now the problem
is that this H pawn is also just just to
quick plate king here if I would go here
then you can simply do this and the H
pawn promotes yeah this is why when
teams one might be six King here and now
yeah I played played the easiest way
Quincy for exchanging the Queen's yeah T
I resigned as after King takes c4h6 the
H porn just promotes yeah very
disappointing end of the game yeah
simply broke down after six hours of of
calculating calculating all this crazy
variations yeah this is some also a bit
of yeah maybe yeah very often nowadays
you have those time controls where you
get this 30 seconds increment at the
and this certainly would have helped him
to to have a little bit more time after
each move but it was very difficult with
a little time to play this position
cause rook to six is terrible but what
can you do I think this was a very very
exciting exciting endgame all this was I
was very surprised to see afterwards
that we didn't really make any huge
mistakes if white would have given the
perpetual it was would be here this
Queen f7 perpetual that Queen edge to f7
year this would have been yeah probably
the logical outcome of the game yeah
okay it's unfortunately a loss that I
need to present here but I think it was
was interesting anyway I hope you
enjoyed it and I will make soon with
maybe some more coverage of this Bilbao
tournament but I need to check what
games have been played yeah thanks for
watching